chris paddock
for panic
second starts is coming off the injured
list with an undisclosed medical issue
he's still just 25 years old john but is
trying to regain that form that he had
in that tremendous rookie campaign two
years ago yeah i really feel like this
is the year that he goes to the next
level when you give a young pitcher a
couple years to maneuver and figure out
this is the year to make the necessary
changes to really kind of develop is
that stud prospect that came up and
aboard for nolan arenado who's having a
sizzling month of may second in the
league in average fourth in ops swung on
and popped into shallow right field
cronenworth back towards the line nola
is there chronoworth will make the call
though and in fair territory about
halfway up the right field line he makes
the catch to end the inning uncle
charlie adam wainwright up on the mound
he turns 40 years old in august now in
his 16th major league season and somehow
pitching almost as well as he ever has
man he stings one out towards right
center bader long run still going over
reaches out makes the catch and seeing
harrison bader close the gap on this
ball has used as per usual manny squares
a baseball up it's hit extremely hard
but you could just see
bader actually closing the distance bam
a former 16th round draft pick out of
high school by the cardinals way back in
2006. it's always interesting when
you've got a teammate and then you face
him you'll see who battles and wins the
execution of ex-teammates
and tommy hits it well out to deep left
o'neal going back looking up gonna go
tommy fan with his first home run of the
season and he gets it against the
redbirds and some revenge tommy fam
taking it out on his former ball club
tommy pham needed that in a big way
and wainwright supplied the pitch to do
it
a hanging breaking ball
and tommy is all over this pitch
gives the padres an early two-nothing
lead
probably more important gives tommy fam
some confidence
o'grady kim and carratini six seven and
eight against wayne right here in the
second brady hits it in the air the
other way to left o'neal charging in got
a late break has to dive and he makes
the catch well the athleticism made up
for the read there i don't know if he
lost it at first or what but he's able
to dive forward make the play and get
out number one here in the second one
out base is empty in the bottom of the
second ha sung kim making his fifth
straight start at shortstop here ha
sunken hits a fly ball to deep left
o'neal going back leaps at the wall
can't get it gonna go another home run
second of the big league career for ha
sung kim he gets wayne right and the
padres have homered in each of the first
two innings
right-handed hitters pulling him out
ma'am in the first kim in the second
three to nothing san diego another
breaking ball i think from
wayne wright this one stays up as well
kim is all over this
nobody out austin nolan now hitting
here's nola first pitch swinging san
juan a deep right towards the corner
carlson going back looking up gonna go
a three run homer and the third home run
in the first three innings
six to nothing padres
austin nola goes petco porch for his
first of the season
nolan got a cutter
away and talking about staying on a
baseball and staying in your legs
he finds the petco porch over there in
right field
[Applause]
three run shot so wainwright has now
allowed as many home runs in this game
against the padres as
he had against san diego in his entire
career entering this start one away in
the top of the fourth now molina over
one he flew out to christian
skies this deep carrying back and this
is just over the wall and gone number
six this year for yachty air molina
cardinals are on the board for the first
time all seems to be jumping a little
bit here at petco park today more so
than we've seen all season
[Applause]
fast ball middle away molina after
fouling off a good change up
again we've seen some guys stay in their
legs today especially using the opposite
field and driving the baseball
two and one to hassan kim fernandez
again very long pause of the bell now
the pitch reached four grounded to the
left side edmonds got it it shortened to
second for one moron's turn is in time
hassan thought he beat it out not the
case though and a 6-4-3 double play
makes it a two-out bases empty situation
here in the fifth close play at first
this ground ball to short watch how
quick he gets the hop gets rid of it
good transition good throw
and yes he got him and miguel diaz here
in his second inning of work one away in
the top of the six lauren otto facing
diaz
leans into this out to the big part of
the yard and gone
number eight for nola
he is one of the best front leg hitters
what i mean is gets into his front side
keeps his hands back watch this he
shifts see he's already
out in front but he can keep his hand
back and then just like a rubber band
uncoiled
down and away
tremendous power and the padres are set
up with runners on the corners here in
the sixth andrei's already leading 6-2
they've got manny machado at the plate
first pitch to manny lined into center
field and a base hit andreoli will come
in and score one run is back and it's
7-2 that ball was toasted up to middle i
don't need a gun to know that that pitch
was that ball exited off his bat at 100
at least
that was one of those matchups that
favored machado good low ball hitter
good against right-handed changeups
and all he did was see the ball watch
this swing
down he loves it
absolute power swing everybody talked
about machado when he was with baltimore
when would the power come he hit a bunch
of doubles
well the power came pretty quickly
grisham to third matano to second on a
wild pitch infield halfway into the
ground ball up the middle diving attempt
edmond can't get it into left field for
a base hit grisham has scored machado
will stop at third padres have gotten
both runs back kimlahan a pitched rbi
single and an 8-2 lead here in the sixth
now austin nola who hit a three-run
homer back in the third
runners on the corner still just one out
out in front hits it well down the left
field line o'neil racing over can't get
there falls down in fair territory manny
has scored kivlahan will be held at
third nola into second with an rbi
double it's nine to two in the sixth
here's o'grady with runners on second
and third one out swings breaks his back
rolls one slowly to the right side i'll
get a run home carpenter picks it up
throws to first and just in time to get
o'grady who nearly beat it out carpenter
absolutely took his time with that for
whatever reason the run scores and now
10-2 here in the sixth bader carpenter
edmond
here in the seventh inning against
pierce bader leans into this out to left
and long gone his fourth this season and
the third solo homer tonight for the
cardinals as they try to
inch back into this one late 7-3 padres
here in the seven long time cardinal
infielder is now going to make his first
professional pitching appearance he
inherits three runners lines it into
left field o'neil coming in can't get
there falls in front of him for a base
hit two runs will score big night for
austin nola at the plate and now a 13-3
padre lead here in the seven
here's the o2 to edmond and that's lying
into center field andreola coming in he
makes the catch about letter high and
that is the ball game a winner 13-3
padres over the cardinals